this video is sponsored by
curiositystream get access to my
streaming service nebula when you sign
up for curiosity stream using the link
in the description
june 23 1988 climate scientist james
hansen is testifying before the united
states senate
this is a crucial moment in the history
of climate change
the moment that the idea of man-made
climate change entered the political
mainstream of the largest emitter on
earth the usa
the science hansen talked about had its
roots in the 19th century
but the ability to study if humankind
was actually having an
influence on the earth's climate really
the idea of
modern climate science as we know it
only came about because of one thing
in the 20th century and it was ending in
the background
of hansen's senate testimonial the cold
war
this may sound like an
oversimplification but i don't think it
is
in order to discover anthropogenic
global warming
scientists needed several things first
of all an understanding of radiative
physics which we already had from
various sources in the 19th and early
20th centuries
but far more challengingly scientists
also needed to be able to
monitor trace gases in the atmosphere
they needed to be able to monitor
what we call diagnostic variables so
air temperature precipitation that kind
of thing over
large distances in space but also large
distances
in time going back a long way into the
past and
last but not least they also needed the
computing power necessary to
process all of that data and unpick the
signals from the noise
and all of that became possible in
and indeed because of the cold war
the cold war between the united states
and its western allies and the soviet
union
and its allies grew directly out of the
second world war
that war was of course a hotbed of
technological innovation
and in particular the study of the
physical environment military officials
realized that understanding the oceans
and the skies
provided a strategic advantage a lack of
understanding of the jet stream for
example
hindered american bombing campaigns over
japan while the japanese military
understanding it
more used the jet stream to admittedly
ineffectively
bomb the continental united states with
fukuoka balloons
when it became apparent that the usa and
the ussr were locked in a struggle for
ideological dominance
after the end of the second world war
interest in general's scientific inquiry
and discovery was reignited on both
sides but to quote spencer wheat writing
in the discovery of global warming
some fields of science were more equal
than others in the long-term advantages
they might provide to the united states
physical geoscience was one of the
privileged fields military officials
recognized that they needed to
understand almost everything about the
environments in which they operated from
the ocean depths to the top of the
atmosphere
so american and soviet scientists were
both extensively
funded most famously this took place in
the space race
with scientists and engineers on both
sides pushing the limits of aerospace
technology further and further
in 1957 the soviets launched sputnik
the earth's first artificial satellite
but
1957 was also a crucial year for an
entirely different reason
july 1st marks the beginning of one of
the great scientific adventures of our
time
the international geophysical year
starting in july 1957
and ending in december 1958 so not
really a year
at all this was an international project
aimed at improving cooperation between
scientists
in the east and in the west prior to
this
american and soviet scientists barely
talked to each other at all
but the death of soviet premier joseph
stalin in 1953 marked the start of a
thawing in
relations culminating in the
international geophysical year in 1957
but while the theme of the event was
cooperation
naturally the countries involved wanted
to gain national prestige by discovering
great things
and potentially some data of military
value
so the usa and the soviet union spent
tons
of money funding a whole range of
geophysical research projects
meanwhile in the 1950s the us and the
ussr
were both funding nuclear weapons
programs as these became more complex
they required more and more
sophisticated computing power to
simulate the effects of different weapon
designs
starting from computing hardware
developed crack codes in world war ii
new frameworks such as the maniac that's
the mathematical and numerical
integrator and calculator
were invented along with new techniques
to use them like the monte carlo method
computing power exploded in the 1950s
and 60s
as did well nuclear weapons
as did the ability to detect trace gases
in the atmosphere along with other
techniques such as reading seismographs
the ability to detect tiny amounts of
radioactive material from nuclear
fallout
became an important way of detecting
nuclear tests
it could tell you where the tests had
taken place and the type of explosion
that had happened
however those same techniques the same
technology could also be used to detect
other radioactive
elements in the atmosphere such as for
example
carbon 14. carbon 14
is a common radioactive isotope of
carbon having two more neutrons in its
nucleus than a normal atom of carbon
it's useful because it can be used to
track human emissions of carbon via
burning fossil fuels
fossil fuels are carbon-based being the
fossilized remains of ancient plant and
animal life
and so specifically contain extremely
ancient
carbon during the hundreds of millions
of years that this carbon is buried in
the ground
the radioactive carbon-14 contained
within almost entirely decays
to the stable far more common carbon-12
so when humans dig up and burn fossil
fuels like coal
the carbon so the soot and the carbon
dioxide that's produced
contains far less carbon 14 than that
typically found in the
active dynamic atmosphere and oceans
using us government money and data
collected from equipment originally
designed to hunt for radioactive fallout
the austrian american chemist hans cerse
announced in 1955
that he had detected this ancient carbon
in the atmosphere
in other words he detected that some
small part of the atmosphere had been
added by humans burning fossil fuels
two years later in the international
geophysical year a young chemist called
charles keeling started taking
incredibly precise measurements of the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere
in antarctica and in hawaii and he found
as we now of course know that those
concentrations
were rising to be clear this is not at
all what the us government
had intended to quote spencer weit again
military agencies were scattering money
with a free hand in the 1950s
without the cold war there would have
been little funding for research on a
subject
nobody had connected with practical
affairs
the us navy had bought an answer to a
question it had
never thought to ask with this
observation that the earth's carbon
dioxide concentration
was increasing and crucially knowing
that it was taking place due to the
burning of this ancient
carbon other scientists started to look
for the telltale signs that
those changes in carbon dioxide
concentrations might be changing the
earth's climate
after all informed by the radiative
physics that had been established
decades previously
the science indicated that the earth
should be warming
using technology developed in the space
race they launched earth observation
satellites collecting data on a
worldwide scale
using funds and infrastructure from the
international geophysical year
they searched for ice cores capturing
both past carbon concentrations and
past temperatures using computers
invented for use in the second world war
and
improved for use in the nuclear weapons
race they analyzed all this data
and came to a striking conclusion
it was this conclusion that hansen
presented to the u.s senate in 1988.
human emissions of carbon had likely
warmed the planet by as much as half a
degree celsius
already and this was only the beginning
within 20 years
the carbon concentration in the
atmosphere was predicted to be higher
than it had ever been in the past
hundred thousand years
meanwhile in 1988 something was winding
down to a close that had led
hanson and other scientists to these
conclusions
most of the technology necessary to get
there
from satellites to radioisotope tracing
to digital computers
was developed in directly funded
by and perhaps will be the
single most significant legacy of
the cold war hansen's conclusions would
not have been possible without the cold
war
just as this video would not have been
possible without curiosity stream
if you're looking for evening viewing
that will make you more aware of the
natural world
curiosity stream is the number one
source of smart documentaries on the
internet
as well as externally produced shows
like nature's mathematics about patterns
and symmetry in the natural world
they also have spectacular original
shows like destination moon
about the role the moon will play in
developing future space flight missions
far further afield
they have documentaries for kids and for
adults about the humanities and about
the sciences
there's literally something for everyone
plus if you sign up for curiosity stream
at the link below
you also get access to streamy nominated
educational streaming service
nebula if curiosity stream is the home
of the best professionally produced
documentaries
nebula is the home of the best indie
educational creators
like it was truly 12 tone and practical
engineering
we upload content early to nebula
include additional
exclusive content and make all our
videos available
without ads that's right no ads on the
entire
website instead we all share the revenue
from people subscribing to the website
so by signing up to curiositystream and
nebula
you're directly supporting the next
generation of educational video content
head on over to curiositystream.com
simon clark and if you sign up by the
25th of april you'll get a whacking
41 off the normal price that's less than
a dollar a month to get access to
curiosity streams library
as well as the constantly evolving
content on nebula
and of course supporting creators like
me that's curiositystream.com
simon clark and be sure to sign up for
the 25th of april to get 41
off thank you so much for watching the
video i really hope that you found it
interesting
of course if you would like to watch
more stuff like this there are plenty of
other videos on my channel
but if you find the development of
atmospheric science an interesting
field an interesting idea then you
should check out the book that i have
just announced called firmament
it's available to pre-order now there'll
be a link in the description to a video
where i talk
all about it here's some recommended
viewing for you next if you like this
then you should like those
and again thank you for watching i'll
see you in the next one